la saison des burgers est officiellement
lancée et bonne nouvelle
l'offre vg se diversifie je trouve
intéressant quand les fabricants se
donne la peine tant qu à nous offrir une
nouvelle option d'être créatif de jouer
avec les saveurs de jouer avec les
ingrédients
nous avons analysé l'ensemble des
burgers vg vendus en épicerie soit une
trentaine de produits de 11 marques
différentes
dans l'ensemble on se trouve quand même
avoir des valeurs nutritives qui sont
plus belles plus intéressante
qu'est ce qu'on voyait du côté de la
restauration sans surprise parce que le
yop un continent ou une sauce au vin
paye rien tout ça on note que la
boulette
la composition des produits est très
bien dans la grande majorité on a très
peu d'habitude beaucoup d'ingrédients
frais relativement peu transformés dont
c'est bien côté sodium de façon générale
notre nos échantillons et avait du
tonnerre assez raisonnable dans tous les
cas c'est pas par soins des produits de
la gamme il se faire que tous les
produits de la gamme sont super les
burgers analysé peuvent être classés en
deux catégories ceux qui assument
pleinement leur profil végétariens et
ceux qui cherchent à imiter la viande
les imitations de viande ondes et les
ingrédients qui sont longues parce
qu'elles ont beaucoup a essayé de copier
en textures et en goût et en couleurs
etc
donc c'est sûr que côté naturalité c'est
les options qui sont un peu moins
intéressante
ils sont parmi les plus graves et les
plus à l'est laissez-les en fait dans ce
genre de produits ne sert à deux choses
le sel est très utilisé pour consigne de
nous donner la saveur et le sel c'est
rossi d'agen lien donc quand les
protéines qui sont utilisés sont
utilisés entre autres formes de farine
on a besoin de poids pour tenir ce rang
semble et il le sait leur rating ou dans
crossing nous donne une texture qui va
sûrement plus intéressant
parmi les produits qui ne cherche pas à
imiter la viande trois produits
québécois se démarque vg gourmet soya
riz et pourra dans le cadre de port à
tous les produits sont à base de tofu
donc on a une protéine de souillac et en
protéines complètes
ce qui est intéressant est du côté de
ceux gary d'un produit à l'autre et des
grandes variations au niveau de la
texture donc si on a envie de quelque
chose de plus ferme ou de plus souples
on peut trouver notre compte dans leur
gamme les produits sont très peu
assaisonner aussi donc on a la
possibilité vraiment d'y ajouter ce
qu'on veut et d'y donner le goût qu'on
souhaite
la gamme vg gourmet a particulièrement
plu à isabelle très belle variété de
saverne belle créativité de recettes
puis des valeurs nutritives dans
l'ensemble qui était vraiment très bien
c'est un parfum d'annette et de légumes
frais qui nous accueille chez vg gournay
en mai des films the fame et sa tente
beaucoup
on a beaucoup de bons ingrédients qui
donnent la saveur vg gourmet fondée en
2016 par chantal et emmanuel couple dans
la vie comme en affaires a aujourd'hui
plus de 700 points de vente au canada
on a démarré l'entreprise parce que
chantal et moi nous sommes des gîtes à
rien puis on aime manger ça des brevets
j'aime ont trouvé parce que nous on
aimait à dire à base de légumes frais de
bonnes fêtes des herbes fraîches
l'astuce et de cuir d'abord les burgers
et décongeler tout de suite
donc ça nous permet d'éviter de mettre
trop d'agents de conservation mais mon
armée aucun et pas beaucoup de sel
les recettes c'est vous qui les
concocter sa vous vient d'où si tous les
récits que je faisais à la maison leurs
produits sont disponibles au rayon des
surgelés
alors que la majorité des autres bugs vg
sont vendus réfrigéré pour réduire sa
consommation de viande pourquoi ne croit
plongée dans un monde de saveurs
végétales le grand avantage des bugs vg
l'apport en fibres de plus en plus elle
lit
produits qu'on nous offre sont des
mélanges need aliments protéinés
d'origine végétale même si de légumes et
de céréales
le soya et la protéine la plus présente
en symbole 2 c'est aussi une des plus
complètes en acides aminés us face au
haschich quinoa pour agent nous haricots
noirs sont aussi présents dans la
plupart des produits que plus qu'une
source de protéines végétales ce qui est
bien parce que ça permet justement
d'aller chercher des combinaisons et
compléter l'ensemble de nos assises
ennemi de city
je pense que le lit seul point
d'amélioration seront à continuer de
faire attention sur quelle source de
protéines sont utilisés en quelle
quantité pour cultiver en plus
véritablement considérer chacun de ces
options loeb comme étant un repas les
bugs vg représente en général une bonne
option qui allie plaisir et bonne
alimentation
[Musique]
le burger vg très populaire au point où
les américains font du 5 juin nationale
b jim barker des fondouks aux états unis
les journaux nationaux de quelque chose
il y en a mille cinq cent par année